guys you asked for it for so long we
finally got it merch is on sale right
now uh we really talk about it but I
want to start pushing it because we have
a really cool designs that Joe and I
made up ourselves and it's the limited
run so whatever is on sale now the
second is sold out it's not coming back
it's available right now uh in the links
on these videos or at our website
savocanocomedy.com Joe derosainfo.com
that's tastebuds merch I also have solo
merch uh up there as well uh and uh so
check all of it out and uh and and buy
some merch tweeted us the merch and we
will retweet you we'll repost you on
Instagram we want to see which ones you
guys are liking and we want to see the
merch out in the wild really cool
project that we put together sort of see
it out there is going to be cool so
check out on March for perch guys I'm on
the road and I hope you come see me let
me tell you where I'm going to be very
soon all tickets on sale right now at
salvolcanocounty.com October I'm in
Hamilton and Toronto uh Richmond
Virginia and Hershey Pennsylvania uh in
November I'm in Knoxville I'm in Atlanta
I'm in Birmingham I'm in Louisville and
I'm in Evansville Indiana uh and in
December I am in Jacksonville Tampa
Florida Orlando Florida Sacramento San
Jose and Santa Rosa California that
rounds out my 2022 of touring
everything's on sale right now we added
second shows in Hershey we had a second
shows in Toronto we had second shows in
the Atlanta and Tampa so thank you guys
so much everybody else I hope to see you
out there all right folks
Joe DeRosa here I got some dates coming
up people from October 7th to the 8th I
will be in William
hey folks Joe DeRosa here I got some
dates to plug October 7th and 8th I will
be in Wilmington North Carolina at dead
crow Comedy Room two shows Friday two
shows Saturday October 14th the 16th I
will be at skank Fest in Las Vegas
Nevada November 3rd Holland Michigan at
the Park Theater November 4th and 5th
Grand Rapids Michigan at The Listening
Room and December 8th through the 10th
at Coastal creative live uh that's
actually kind of special the Thursday
show December 8th is going to be we'll
see you in hell live
and then Friday and Saturday I'm doing
stand-up shows live so come out to all
these shows go to
jodarosainfo.com for all ticket pricing
and purchasing and show info and all
that sort of stuff uh and there's more
dates being added all the time I've got
20 23 dates coming very soon I hope to
see you out there also if you're in New
York City please come by Joey roses my
bar and sandwich shop on the Lower East
Side a great time we open at 12 P.M
every day Tuesday through Sunday we are
serving drinks and sandwiches the live
long day and evening come on through
Joey
rose'snyc.com for all the info
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic hey folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e Buds and I do the chant solo
today no matter what happens I love you
did I do it you did it all right at the
wrong time but you did it all right and
there is no right or wrong here at taste
buds I say yeah I say It's Only Love uh
to my left the Mighty Quinn Brian Quinn
is here filling in for salvocano how are
you buddy doing great man doing great
I'm just glad I'm glad to see you I'm
glad to see you bud I'm seeing a lot of
you we've been seeing a lot of each
other lately and I I can say complaint
free I complain free as well plain free
we just I like seeing that'll change
after this episode today
now I'm familiar with your routines you
know what I really you know what I
realized about myself this morning and
it and some people would say it's sad I
think it's a gift
I'm like the anti-barber Walters like no
matter who you sit me with on a couch I
can get you to start arguing and
frustrate you
a gift I have today and I was
like oh I can't do taste buds anymore
I'd say I'll miss you but no problem
because I'll irritate anybody that sits
on this welcome to Joe's angry couch
yeah yeah but you said something to me
uh we went to uh Phoenixville yes we
were down in feesville for a few days
you and I shooting something together
yeah shooting something uh something
together
um I'm not on camera I would like to
stress that yes it's not like I don't
want people to think like that I'm uh
going around putting myself on camera
this is all about you well it's all
about the subject and I just am the host
of this thing yeah I'm producing but you
are producing it's very exciting and you
stepped on the camera here and there for
fun sure just to show them that we could
have guests on here and yeah but but
yeah yes
um but we had fun down there a lot of
fun great town Phoenix Phoenixville
Amazing Town uh in the middle of
Pennsylvania yeah we're going again
October yes we're going in October see a
movie at the Colonial Theater at the
Colonial Theater which I'm wearing the
shirt that I bought at the club that
they gave me they gave me this which was
very sweet Colonial Theater in
Phoenixville is the theater where they
shot the uh certain sequence the movie
theater sequences of The Blob the
original blob
this is a shirt you know this style of
shirt is popular but these are all the
characters from The Blob yeah
um
I still have the remnants of a cough
because I got sick as a dog down there
yeah I thought you were gonna get me
sick but it turned out you didn't I
don't even I still don't know if it was
just allergies or what could have been I
mean my God but here's the big news and
we're burying the lead
and pimp I got to send you this stuff
right now
Phoenixville is the town next to the
town I grew up in I grew up in
Collegeville or sometimes it's called
trap
um
and while we were in Phoenixville Brian
brought up the ditch
the famous ditch we were seven minutes
away from the ditch
not only did we go I got a video right
here a six minute video where he gives a
tour of the ditch yeah yeah I we
Revisited the ditch
uh and I've got video to prove it right
here yeah it was it was
um
more poignant
like because you could go to the ditch
with two attitudes right like oh let's
go see the stupid ditching but we didn't
take that attitude we went like we took
it for what it is it was an important
part of your childhood and it meant
something to you and like so we didn't
go in like haha let's go look at this
ditch we went in like
let's go see the dick let's go see today
took it seriously you gave a tour yes
and you spoke I I feel pretty poignantly
about the ditch well I I'm I'm and I'm
and everything you're saying is is truly
resonating with me by the way I'm just
looking at my phone not to no no I have
interest I'm just trying to send this
yeah I'll I'll I'm talking to the
audience too um I'm letting them know
because you're a consummate profesh yeah
I want that to understand I got an email
at pimp it's too long you're probably
gonna get it in a Google link can
airdrop that to him oh how do you do
that you want me to do it yeah here's my
phone pimp air drop it to yourself I
don't know it's like a mini documentary
on the ditch yeah
here
so yeah we go to the ditch
actually it's all on camera every
revelation of the ditch was caught on
camera we we did a six minute video
there's some pictures we took a picture
of me staring into it not sitting and
staring because the ground was filthy
yeah the ditch much like a girlfriend
that you dated in high school and you
and and you see years later the ditch
wasn't the same no
no and and you'll see in the you'll see
in the video you'll see in the video
it's it's it's completely I just called
my dad about it yesterday
and I was like yeah Dad it's weird it's
like all overgrown now because they
planted like trees and stuff in it and I
said dad I gotta be honest with you
it looked better when it was just a
clean empty ditch like now it looks like
God knows what could be in kind of
Swampy yeah like but he told me when we
were when I was a kid he goes he goes
remember we had muskrats down there
going in and out of the drawer oh yeah
and I was I was like no I don't but
but everything I told you at that ditch
he remembered all of it really yeah the
tale of spooky the dog which will be on
there yeah do you know about spooky the
dog oh you're gonna learn all about it
it's in the video but you said something
to me this is how we got started on this
okay because this is I'm tying two
things to your couch Joe's angry couch
and Phoenixville you said to me
in Phoenixville something that kind of
hurt my heart a little bit and I was
like oh man like I didn't I hope like I
felt kind of bad I didn't mention it at
the time and I didn't know if I was ever
going to mention it to you but since
we're here on camera Now's the Time you
said that you got our relationship off
on the wrong foot do you remember saying
this to me yeah yeah you were like bro
because I love ball busting I know me
too I I love it like and I my ball
buffing busting sorry is always
the most toothless ball busting like I
never I never tried to put any bite
behind it right I like to you know
little swipes I you know I don't like
being mean right you you had said that
you think that you got our friendship
off on the wrong foot because now I ball
bust too much with you
well that upset me I didn't quite mean
that okay let me let me explain what I
meant
I have a tendency to get into routines
with people yeah
yeah where the the consistent air back
and forth is antagonistic yeah you know
what we let me rephrase that not even
the consistent the go-to is antagonistic
sure and then that's the thing that you
have to get past
first to get to the other stuff yeah and
you do get to the other stuff
but I've created that Dynamic many times
in my life with friends because it's
like I come into it like ball breaking
or whatever
and you're good at it thank you you're
good at it too thank you uh and the
thing is is our relationship our
friendship was built
well it wasn't built we were already
friend we were friends but I would say
our friendship elevated to a new level
when we started playing beer pong at
that summer house together yeah and
really like getting into the frustration
and competition of it all and talking
[ __ ] and all that stuff which you've
talked about on the Pod and I've talked
about it yeah so
that
that's why I said that I was like I know
because you were not antagonistic in
beer pong no you were very just like
let's just play the game man no I was
gobsmacked a little bit because you were
just hammering me hey like like I was
just trying to have fun so it's like so
I had to rise to the challenge yeah and
you would get very visually frustrated
and you pace around you you get very
angry and I thought it was funny and
then I would keep doing it so that's
what I meant at the table when I felt
okay I was sick that day
and we had to go shoot
and I was like in my head like [ __ ] man
I don't feel good but we got to go shoot
today
and then I sat down and we were I was
like like shoveling that [ __ ] veggie
burger down so we could go shoot and
then you were busting my stones and
that's where I said I was like
I did this to myself I can't ask you to
lay off of me right now because I
realize I have started this Dynamic but
you can you can ask me to lay off
because like I don't I it's I don't view
our friendship as one of mainly ball
busting I just don't like it's an
element of it that in my mind was kind
of regulated to beer pong but then when
you said that I I was like oh man am I
like taking shots in them when I
shouldn't be I'm like I I I don't see
that as a Cornerstone in our
relationship and what I was doing that
day was because you were not feeling
well
um
and and you had to be on camera and you
did a great job but my thing was just
like a light touch a little ball busting
my PO you know lift lift all yeah lift
all boats yeah and I was and I was
saying ah Christ I'm not in the mood but
I have no right to tell you you have
every right to say I know you're saying
that now but but and I get that yeah I'm
just telling you what I meant I'm
justifying what I meant when I said the
thing that hurt your heart yeah yeah
that was not about you that was about or
about us that was about me saying uh you
did it to yourself again yeah yeah okay
I understand now you know I understand
uh Xiao and I
Sal and I never argued except about food
once in a while which is why we started
the show
um I believe that our friendship is now
in a place that can never be repaired uh
we argue all the time almost about
everything uh because of this show yeah
so I'm telling you I know I know when it
can go bad you're the second child I'm
not gonna make the mistakes I made with
the first kid with you so you're saying
it went bad with Sal it's it's bad Sal's
the kid that's not good he's my oldest
he's not gonna show up at all the
holidays
you're gonna have a much higher opinion
of me when I when I go at the funeral
you'll do the eulogy probably me yeah
all right I got it yeah yeah yeah all
right that's good that's good yeah so
um but yeah no man we had a great time
down there we I don't want to talk about
what we were doing uh because it'll be
more because you don't want to you know
yeah
but it was fun we had a great shoot
great shoot and one of the places we
visited was the Colonial Theater which
we're going to go back to on um October
1st yeah to watch
how cool is this a double feature
for the beginning of Halloween month of
Evil Dead 2 and Cabin in the Woods like
two of my favorite [ __ ] horror movies
and Cabin in the Woods is digital a
digital projection the they got a 35
millimeter print of Evil Dead 2. I've
never seen Evil Dead 2 and it's one of
my favorite movies like top three
favorite movies love it and I've never
seen them in theaters so I can't I can't
wait so I went to I have two quick Evil
Dead Two stories okay
I did see part of it in the theater
because one Halloween when I lived in
Austin I ate mushrooms with my friends
and we went to see it and I I had such a
bad trip I wonder why I mean dude I was
I was in a full panic attack like full
you actually told us about it I think
you're on your couch okay yeah so I
won't go into the story again but I left
Evil Dead too uh this was like I can't
handle this right now okay and then I
went into Best in Show because that was
like new in the theater okay good choice
and that freaked me out even more really
I remember I walked in on the scene it
was a scene where Eugene Levy goes I
have two left feet that's not a
euphemism and it pants down and I was
like
and I went home but um but the cooler
Evil Dead 2 story
I was in LA at the time I was living in
LA and my friend pat patty Walsh who I
do will see you in hell with which by
the way we still got to have you on
yeah
um
we've only ever had two guests you would
be the third guest ever I'm excited to
be a guest yeah yeah we got to have you
on I'm worried if I'm sweating through
my shirt you look you don't look like
I'm not all right you guys really you
keep it warm in here it's uh
you know it's only an apartment owned by
a multi-millionaire
the way you're doing this people think I
don't know don't say it just in case you
know but yeah
a man with money owns this place very
rich person's apartment yeah yeah that
were crashing in and it was hard to
figure out the Wi-Fi even yeah it's
pretty warm in here yeah but all right
so I'm just if you see me doing this
it's not why I normally do it which is
like do I look fat it's like am I
sweating through my my shirt no I I do
that too yeah yeah mine is though do I
look fat yep anyway we
um so I my friend Patty Walsh uh used to
write for It's Always Sunny so he got
invited to the season whatever Premiere
it was years after he wrote to the show
and we went we were at the after party
Glenn Howerton who plays Dennis is my
favorite character on the show yeah
Dennis system man he's oh my God I just
saw that podcast live Sunday night I
went to Philly I saw Always Sunny
podcast live oh really they were great
oh that would have been cool yeah
um I guess that's why Sal called me and
not you for it you two were [ __ ]
fighting that's cool
I didn't get to meet them I was like oh
shall go down he came we went down
that's nice I'm glad he found time it's
not a time to make it down to us
Philly for somebody else's to watch
somebody else's pose great well we were
hoping we were going to meet the you
know the three guys because we've been
fans of the show and oddly they've been
they're on for most of their run in an
hour on we've aired I think in
competition to each other but I've never
given a [ __ ] I'm like I don't [ __ ]
Always Sunny this is great like watch
Always Sunny like our show's on all the
time yeah I love that show so we were
going to go down there and and get and
we were like yeah we could go backstage
meet the guys which was big like I'm a
legit fan of Always Sunny love it and
then we got there and we saw someone
that we had like a a promoter that we
haven't seen in a while and ended up
talking to him until the show started uh
and then they left they walked off stage
which which I understand nothing on them
like that's what I do after stage so I
didn't all that I didn't even get to
meet those guys that's uh that's that's
interesting I think they got away with
more than even Family Guy their jokes
were wild they got away with the most
which is why it's a bummer to me that
sometimes on the podcast well I heard
Rob mcelany say this once and uh but it
bummed me out
he talked about one of the or the
episode where they they they go to the
he goes to the coach
oh and he's like yeah
and Rob McAllen said on the podcast
she's like you know I I get now that
something along the lines if I get now
this this type of joke isn't funny and
it's like yes it is dude yes it is I
know we're in a different world and I
know that you're much bigger but it's
funny dude yeah so it's funny I mean he
also got older you know things like that
happen I hope they don't sterilize the
show I guess you know moving forward I
hope not yeah I hope not too but anyway
but I don't think they will I don't
think they know what they're doing that
cast is great I love the show I love the
crew I've met rob a million times she's
always very cool whenever I see him
um I met all of them robbed is the one I
kind of know but um Dennis
Glenn Howerton I didn't know at all
and we were at the premiere party the
after party and we were upstairs in the
bar that it was at and Glenn Harrington
was the only cast member that was
upstairs
and I was like
I I said to patago I really want to
[ __ ] meet him man like I just think
he's amazing I think AP Bio is hilarious
like
and Pat introduced me and as he was
Introducing Me Glenn goes hey dude nice
to meet you and he goes hey we're just
talking about
um that like Wizard of Oz Pink Floyd
thing and I go oh no [ __ ] and I go you
know what I did recently
and he goes what and I go
I don't know why I just tried it and it
actually kind of worked I got high and I
put on Evil Dead 2 and I put on metal
the the metal album by Pink Floyd and it
kind of sunk up really and he goes wait
what hold on dude hold on dude you're my
new best friend now hold on and he went
off and had to say bye to somebody and
he came back and he goes Evil Dead 2 is
my favorite movie yeah really I want to
talk about this and he goes and I love
the album metal let's talk about this
and we started talking and we hung out
for like an hour oh well that's cool
just kind of kicking it having drinks
like talking about horror movies talking
about
when I said to him
and it was cool because he got it and he
got that I wasn't Fanning out like he
just got it was it was a cool moment I
go
it was the season when he had left and
he wasn't going to come back but then he
came back yeah that was weird because he
was only gone like three episodes I know
right yeah
and they showed the episode where he
comes back and I go dude coming into the
theater I go this is the only thing I'll
say to you as a fan outside of this we
just talk as people because I get it I
understand that that'll be annoying and
I go seeing the episode tonight I didn't
know if you were going to come back or
not
uh when you showed up on camera I go
dude as a fan of this show that for me
was like when Han Solo walked back onto
the phone yeah I see I agree yeah it was
big yeah and he was like he's like yes
dude that's [ __ ] like he just got it
he got that I wasn't ball washing him
right he he also without being too in
his own ego understood why it was cool
to a fan yeah without it being like like
well of course it was looking you know
what I mean I'm sure he's happy to hear
it like yeah you know it was it was he
was cool man right they were then I saw
I saw Rob that night too and Rob was
really cool he's a ball breaker is he
yeah he was I never met any of those
guys I had one interaction with Charlie
Day yeah
um he was I I guess maybe he was
shooting uh except [ __ ] Kaiju movie
Pacific Rim or whatever I don't know I
was driving off and I believe this is I
can only say this four times in my life
like this isn't like I saw but like I
was driving off the fox or Paramount lot
in La we'd gone there for some [ __ ]
meeting and uh the the car my car was
coming out of the front gate and his was
coming in and security had stopped him
and security stopped me going out for
some reason so we're just sitting next
to each other and I look over and I'm
like holy [ __ ] it's Charlie you know and
it's that thing and people do it to me
all the time and they're like oh it's
Charlie I know him yeah so I wrote down
the window I go oh man I go I love you
and he goes I love you man
I was he was just doing it like he
wasn't like I know Impractical Jokers I
love you he was like he's like I love
you man and then security let us both go
and that was my interaction with Charlie
day and I it was enough for me I was
like that was really that was like a
nice little moment I bet that was when
he was my friend was doing a sitcom
called the cool kids I think that was on
that lot oh no no no I'm sorry you said
it was Pacific Rim he was doing oh I
don't I have no idea I'm just I don't
know why he would be there I'm just but
Pat same guy Pat Walsh was running a
sick it was a showrunner and a sitcom
called the cool kids the Charlie day I
guess created okay
or was EP on or something and uh I think
they did it at pair I think they did it
I might even have the wrong Studio you
know whatever whatever but that was it
that was my only interaction with those
guys um I was hoping for more Sunday but
I didn't get it that's cool
uh but I don't know where we're at so
evil dead but he loved Evil Dead yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no let's let's get
the focus off of the trip that was made
down to Philly on Sunday I didn't do
anything wrong no you didn't you didn't
you didn't great I mean you got any
thoughts on this
uh
I know what you're thinking
well you guys take that up a towel
that's got my name's Paul this is
between y'all I think I will be taking
this up with so I'm [ __ ] around
um and by the way I gotta point out I
put this right next to me the [ __ ] Pig
himself right here
I went to San Gennaro with him last
night and he ate maybe 4 000 calories in
20 minutes
animal dude
he's an animal he had sausage and
peppers two cannolis stuffed peppers
Cinnamon Toast Crunch milkshake and two
slices of pizza oh that sounds so good
it's so much not the cinnamon toast
crunch but the red like the sausage and
peppers this yeah yeah no no all of it
individually except for the milkshake
sounds good to me
at least he's like six eight isn't he
like a big boy he's huge not big enough
to hide all that no Chris is like six
too really yeah
Bobby Lee said the funny when I was on
the Pike when I was on uh not bad
friends uh uh tiger lily tigerbelly
uh with Bobby Lee when I was in LA and
Chris
he brought up Chris it probably goes
it's disappointing in real life you
think he's gonna be better looking
[Laughter]
yeah it was so funny you guys like Saint
Gennaro have you I love sanchinaro
um I'm gonna avoid it this year because
I'm on this new diet
of uh you know I'm really really cut way
back on meat and trying to cut back on
the booze and all that stuff but uh
but uh so San Gennaro's not a fun place
yeah if you're not eating sausage or
drinking it's the only thing you haven't
really roses too I know I've tasted the
sandwiches enough times I know what they
taste like uh and I'll taste test the
new ones but but yeah I don't know are
you gonna go I'm not gonna go this year
I probably won't go this year uh but I
have gone many times you know I've
probably been like 10 times over the
course of my life when I was young young
and my parents would bring me uh I
remember really loving it it wasn't as
crowded like something happened in my
20s where I went and I was like this is
too much like I there's too many people
like and now it's just too many people
to be enjoyable it's a lot of people and
and also too like the fact that it's
happening is I'm getting over this bug
that I still have the fingering cough
from
yeah the idea of going into a crowded
whatever right now there's photo shoots
going on now it's all about social media
oh yeah
oh I do this thing um I'm big on webcams
have I ever told you this like I watch
them constantly like I'll put them on my
house and just leave them running like
the zoo or like the zoo I'll do animal
ones but there's two I love there's one
in Key West
um uh by uh outside of Irish Kevin's and
then there's one outside the Temple Bar
in Dublin you ever go to Temple Bar in
Dublin it's a big famous bar there I
don't I mean I don't think I went when I
was there but I don't remember and
they're great for two reasons like one
the Dr that's it the drunks and their
sound too so you could hear
conversations and stuff the drunks uh at
night are it's you can't beat the
entertainment like you like people
watching you sit in a bar and people
watch
you could sit here and watch us and just
have the same experience okay and I've
noticed in the past couple of years so
many so many of his girls just like
doing like
the like a photo shoot or like hear your
boyfriend take 50 photos and they do the
hair flip and turn around I I don't hate
much and I'm not typically a salty dude
but these like I don't know what's going
on like I hate these photo shoots the
the synchronized dance that they all do
on Tic Tac I'm like you girls are
destroying what makes you special with
this [ __ ] I feel like girls date me
for head shots it's so bad man it's like
you're out you're you're a Temple Bar
and like you're just doing a photo shoot
and you're like dude this sucks you suck
you you suck because you have no shame
to do it in front of everybody and
everybody else you look stupid it's
gross and it and it perpetuates uh it
perpetuates a certain Prejudice in your
head
about what what people are going to do
folks prize picks prize picks prize
picks when it comes to daily fantasy
placing entries uh player projections
Etc you want to go to prize picks all
right they are making it easier more
versatile and more fun than anybody else
out there on the internet when it comes
to your fantasy entry projections and
all that sort of thing what I really
like about prize picks is I'm a guy that
doesn't understand Sports I don't really
know sports but I do like this type of
involvement in sports I find it very fun
I find it exciting uh
prize picks makes it not only easy for a
bonehead like me to understand okay and
on how all this works for instance by
showing you basically percentages uh
instead of getting into terms like over
under and all that sort of thing by just
showing you in Stark easy to understand
black and white numbers what something
the return on something would be versus
the risk or whatever
it makes it just completely easy to
understand how this all works and I like
that because again I'm not a sports guy
but I like this sort of thing when it
comes to sports
um I also like the versatility of prize
picks you trust me there's something out
there for you uh if you want to get
involved in uh this kind of fun uh
there's the you know they they got the
NFL the NBA the MLB the NHL the PGA the
college football men's college
basketball women's college basketball
soccer the WNBA uh Esports NASCAR tennis
MMA boxing uh disc golf Euro basketball
Cricket for God's sake it just goes on
and on and on and your entries can be
made in 60 seconds or less it's that
easy and these withdrawals are safe and
fast prize picks is currently
operational in over 30 States and Canada
so look go download the prize picks app
you're gonna have a good time or go to
prize picks.com to sign up and play
daily fantasy sports first time users
can receive 100 instant deposit that
will match up to a hundred dollars with
the promo code taste buds so that means
if you deposit 100 bucks prize picks
will give you a hundred bucks if he
devise it 50 bucks price picks will give
you 50 bucks you get it don't forget to
enter your promo code taste buds at sign
up for an instant deposit match of up to
a hundred dollars prize picks butcher
box
folks what is your typical grocery
experience I will tell you mine I go
when I don't have time I go when I'm not
in the mood uh and I go and I can't find
half of the meat products I want because
uh the store doesn't have the ones I
want and if they do have the ones I want
it's not the cut I want if they do have
the cut I want it's not the price I want
butcher box
has what you need
they're going to speak to every issue I
just said how convenient sending it to
your front door
uh price making it more affordable than
anywhere else
uh the cuts you want quality cuts only
the best cuts
this is what butcher Box is doing for
you it's alleviating this headache of
the grocery store meat hunt
which I know is not the most attractive
way to put it but that's how I'm putting
it it's a meat hunt out there butcher
box is offering new members free New
York strip steaks two of them two free
New York strip steaks and eight ounces
of cold crack Lobster in your first box
plus ten dollars off folks that's two
free New York strip steaks and eight
ounces of cold crack Lobster in your
first box plus ten dollars off what more
do you want give it a try
butcher Box gives you peace of mind all
right they're taking the guesswork out
of finding the high quality Meat and
seafood you can trust it's ultimate
convenience you get what you want
delivered right to your doorstep and
it's an incredible value again enjoy a
range of high quality cuts that are hard
to come by at the grocery store at an
amazing price
enough already do it they saving you
money they've saved me money I've used
this service it's a great service you
know we talk about it almost every
episode so butcher box again offering
our listeners free New York strip steaks
two of them plus Lobster plus 10 bucks
off your first box just just just do it
sign up today at butcherbox.com
tastebuds and get two 10 ounce New York
strip steaks and eight ounces of Lobster
Claw and knuckle meat free in your first
order plus ten dollars off your first
box that's butcherbox.com taste buds you
know this thing just came out about uh
Adam Levine or whatever his name is what
happened with Adam Levine he apparently
had an affair with a with a with a
influencer oh that sounds like a smart
maneuver yeah
that won't abuse it for power yeah [ __ ]
move on his part but then he tries to
name the the thing is he's supposedly
tried to name his baby with his wife
after the influencer
who knows how much of this is true how
much is it but my initial response to it
is Adam Levine is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
this lady for cloud chasing like this
yeah because nothing with so many people
now is private it's like can't anybody
just have quiet shame anymore can't
anybody just take a silent defeat
anymore everything now has to be
exploited and like here's all my dirt
and here's all my dirty laundry and
here's what happened to me and this is
it's like you know man like there's
something dignified and about Grace
about like
hey man I've taken some files and I've
had some dark personal times it's not
for everybody all the time are you
talking about [ __ ] Adam Levine
be like well we had a year-long affair
and this it's like yeah what are you
doing what is this a gossip rat like
what stop like everybody's a gossip rag
now like it's just gross it's not gonna
I don't think it's gonna lead to what
they want either like nobody's gonna be
like you're
I assume Adam Levine is having Affairs
here's what's going to happen
everybody's gonna call Adam Levine an
[ __ ] for two months yeah and then
he's gonna go away and have a kid and
then he's gonna come back in two years
with a new Maroon 5 record and
everybody's gonna go oh my God it's
brilliant and that's and that's going to
be the end of it it's such fleeting
it's it's just a thing you don't want to
be defined by but people it it's like
it's small armed robbery
uh uh or stronger because I'm using the
wrong term but you know what I mean it's
small time it's small time Crooks it's
we're gonna go in and do a smash and
grab
and so yeah but you're not thinking
about the big picture yeah especially
like something like that where it's like
you had an affair and I mean look I
don't know I'm just learning about this
from you but like especially if nothing
like if he beat the [ __ ] out of her then
by all means like sure yeah like I don't
you know but I mean it doesn't sound
like that happened I don't know I don't
know anything about it but from what I
saw in the headlines it was no there was
no accusation or and when I the little
bit I read of the story there was no
accusation of anything right it was just
like can you believe this dildo tries to
name his [ __ ] that is a weird move I
will say this in his defense I met him
and he was so nice to me he was warm and
generous and nice to me so you know
whatever you think of Adam Levine I just
letting you know like I met the guy he
was [ __ ] sweetie I'm sure Tiger Woods
is a [ __ ] dream you know what I mean
when you talk to him buddy you know the
guy likes the guy likes a little
[ __ ] something on the side you know
yeah but
I don't know man I just this just this
concept anymore of like I will achieve
uh longevity and notoriety by the means
of promoting and producing my art or
pursuing a craft of some sort or or a
trade in the Arts or whatever is is is
disappearing
and you're seeing more and more of these
people like going after this like
fleeting celebrity and I guess it's not
that different like you know you know
like Marie Antoinette was like was like
the first
Paris Hilton or whatever yeah yeah so
like it's like yeah she was like
considered like a socialite like
whatever okay
I think I'm pretty sure there's
influencers I don't know huh the royal
families throughout history will
influence yeah so like I guess it's not
anything new it's just more accessible
now than before but it bums me out
everyone's a [ __ ] influence like
everybody's making content you can't
escape it yeah but that's all right like
but it's also well that's fine yeah it
just it bums me out that it's like
that P
it it the the definition of all this
stuff starts to get polluted after a
while these terms get bastardized yeah
and and it just and everybody's the the
fruit gets lower and lower and then the
lower it gets the more people go to grab
it and then all of a sudden it's like
everybody's focused on the wrong thing
right now you know what I mean so but I
mean I remember I read an article that
was like
comedians are making waves on Tick Tock
and I was like okay and I and I looked
at the article and I knew most of the
guys on it and their friends some of
them are friends of mine but they were
like putting up guy they were like
highlighting guys that had like 22 000
Tick Tock followers I'm like what is
this because the person that writes the
article doesn't give a [ __ ] either yeah
they're like let me just see what's
going and then they just that's it or
they'll go and influence or got in
trouble and then you go to their profile
and it's like they have 35
000 followers on Instagram like that's
what an influencer is now it was like
when you had a million five that meant
influencer or that person paid for the
article
oh because that's the other side of that
business yeah there's yeah the whole
Payola yeah new Payola whatever anyway
what are we talking about let's get to
the battle Yeah because you
you were late I wasn't late well you
were seven minutes late all right
um I was in the parking lot uh so we
have like 22 minutes okay let's go all
right and I know you know I know what
we're really gonna get down to this is
ultimately gonna be an argument about
back in the Future Part three well hold
on hold on yeah
all right here we go time for
b-a-t-t-l-e budge folks it's the Back to
the Future franchise versus the Star
Wars franchise you probably know what
side I'm on and yes it is the Star Wars
franchise Brian Quinn my dear friend
foolishly
things that back to the Futures
franchise as a Star Wars fan he thinks
it has legs against this franchise uh
well you know I'd like you to give me an
opening statement Brian on why now by
the way there was some pushback
about the Back to the Future not being a
franchise from who Joe
the cold coming back up again uh
but uh but as you as you were saying to
me and I was agreeing and I was saying
the channels no Back to the Future is a
franchise there are video games there's
a cartoon animated series there's uh
there's video games yes there's Rick and
Morty was originally called Doc and
Marty supposed to be back to the future
there's a Broadway play coming next year
so it's like that's a franchise what
more do you need to do a franchise and
there's always talk of will there ever
be a part four which I doubt but I
promise you they'll do some sort of
reboot or something at something not
till domestic right you know well we'll
see I mean zemekas did just make
Pinocchio yeah I didn't see it
why is why are people saying it is why
everybody's saying it's the worst piece
of [ __ ] but why nobody's telling me why
it is a it's not a beat for beat remake
of this it's a movie it's a beat it's an
almost beat for beat remake of the
cartoon
what changes do they make changes that I
couldn't even really speak to just when
you see it in the movie you're like oh
that obviously wasn't in the cartoon but
like the island where he turns into a
donkey not good the whale thing not good
you would think that would all be fun no
it's it's a movie with like four real
people in it and then everything around
them is CGI so you're going why did you
make an animated movie animated that has
like a live Tom Hanks in it yeah Tom
Hanks is passable or serviceable in it
it's getting annoying like this is the
role that kind of breaks the camel's
back for me with him where it's like my
friend my friend said it best take if he
goes take a day off it's like
good I think I think that's his second
bomb of the Year Elvis was a bomb
how dare you hold on we don't have time
to divert now okay all right
the movie stinks the SE things and it's
the 87th thing I've seen Keegan Michael
Keane this week you're like bro for the
love of God so what is he supposed to
say no when he gets a paycheck you got
to take it you know what yes he should
say no once at all he's not out there
[ __ ] directing nope like the mother
like he needs it's enough already take a
day off for the love of God like it's
like you if you were in those shoes I
don't think you'd take a day off
bro if yeah I would you don't know me
very well my mer my work ethic goes to
an extent yeah but I'm not talking about
work either you think if they call them
and they're like hey man they're gonna
give you they're going to cut you a
check for [ __ ] 300 000 to [ __ ] do
Pinocchio and I go what else I got this
week and they go well you got to play uh
you gotta play a rat in the live-action
rat tattooing how much is that guys no
he's already booked for that and then
also we got you in a in a sketch on SNL
and then also uh you're hosting a game
show I go you know what no I'm not gonna
do the other thing I'm not sure I'm
telling you I don't believe you you
would be like holy [ __ ] now I could
afford a bigger pool now I could afford
that boat I want now I'm gonna get that
[ __ ] car and all I gotta do is stand
in a booth and be like Pinocchio you
gotta remember motion cap it's full
motion or whatever man put the balls on
me I'll be I'll
Brock in the Park yeah all right so
walking but I'm sure he's getting paid
uh but wait we're wasting valuable
minutes we are okay I love me I'm sure
he's getting paid I wouldn't put myself
in a position where I would like I'm
putting Star Wars against Back to the
Future because I have to but like
normally I wouldn't be like Back to the
Future is better than Star Wars but here
we are
and I'm gonna I'm going to do what I
normally do and talk about the you know
positives of Back to the Future
not why Star Wars sucks because for the
most part I don't think Star Wars sucks
but you do think fairly yeah that the
amount of Star Wars content has lessened
the overall value of that franchise yes
my feeling is Star Wars and and it's
gonna sound like a slam but it's not
Star Wars is after George Lucas is
involved it's essentially fan fiction at
this point I wouldn't argue that yeah so
to me I'm like but I which is by the way
why I said this had to be because that
was like just do Trilogy versus Trilogy
I was like no
yeah that Star Wars then will bury it
it'll be original trailer there's just
it's just not right there's no chance
once you expand it to franchises
now I would actually make the argument
for Back to the Future that the lesser
amount of content has preserved that
original trilogy the original Star Wars
Trilogy magical as it is has been I
think in quality depleted by the amount
of other stuff that's been built up
around it because you can't watch it now
without seeing all the connections that
they've made to some other things yes
right go ahead and also less is more
sometimes the Matrix was way better when
you didn't know what city they lived in
when they were unplugged
and when you didn't have to watch this
awful [ __ ] fourth installment reboot
that they did uh or that third [ __ ] show
whatever you know what I mean the Matrix
when it was just Matrix one great and
there was all this mystery if you didn't
live during through it you don't know
what it was like the Matrix was a
[ __ ] Phenom like you it was the new
Star Wars obsessed with it yeah yeah so
anyway tell me why Back to the Future
you think is great
well I think the reason everybody thinks
Back to the Future is great like it's
the car I mean that's it's kind of a
crazy question like why do you think
Star Wars is great but but you said you
were going to talk about the positives
Back to the Future sure but like all
right well look but I know where we're
headed with this I almost want to just
jump through no no go ahead all right go
ahead the first one's a masterpiece
first one's a masterpiece [ __ ]
Masterpiece it's it's it's a creative
idea uh that you don't I don't know if
they'd make it today you know him trying
to him with his mom and all that [ __ ]
like you don't know not that that
matters and that's overused anyway I
think but like you haven't seen anything
like that in I mean the con the weight I
mean the concept of time travel they
made time travel fun the DeLorean is
like nothing I've ever seen before the
DeLorean was my like I it was like
before I was into women like I wanted to
[ __ ] the DeLorean uh the DeLorean is
cool but I will tell you what lessons
the DeLorean what lessons is DeLorean as
kids when we saw Back to the Future yeah
and we didn't know what the [ __ ] of
DeLorean really was sure we just saw
that car and it looked so cool and Marty
goes you made a time machine out of a
DeLorean and it's just kind of funny and
you're like whatever I don't get it uh
you go back to it now and you're like oh
that was like a DeLorean joke like
because the DeLorean failed
like it was this supposed to be the car
of the future and it failed and then
they make this like DeLorean joke it
works on in the other way too though
what like I never thought that it's a
Shameless
product Place well they had the well the
business it was out of business already
wasn't it but then I don't know I don't
know but my point is is
that when I got older and I and I you
started to see the documentaries about
John DeLorean and then uh the movie
about John O'Leary it took away from
what that was for me it wasn't quite as
magical okay it wasn't quite as this
machine from elsewhere that I had never
seen and whatever like let's say the
Millennium Falcon but it's not my turn
to talk it's your turn no no we could
talk because I love the Millennium
Falcon like like that's why we're in
such a pickle right now because I love
both but the DeLorean was the thing like
look I put it this way the Millennium
Falcon which I love you know I love it
I've [ __ ] tributed to it in my house
um
is at the end of the day a spaceship
right and like you could have kind of
those Adventures as a child in your head
with on your bed with a spaceship
something about turning a car or vehicle
into a time machine open things up more
for me in my mind like suddenly my bike
was a time machine you know what I mean
like when I was a kid and like if I
pedaled fast enough I broke the barrier
Brian wasn't a bright kid folks no what
are you talking about my adorable kid
okay no my bike was my bike was a
Transformer right you know when I was a
kid and my bike was a DeLorean my bike
couldn't be the Millennium Falcon right
it could be the Speeder bike on Endor
right but it wasn't it couldn't be the
Millennium Falcon whereas anything it
once you make a car into a time machine
to me that busts open the imagination
and then they make a train into a time
machine well don't get ahead of yourself
don't go right to where the the entire
franchise sucks that's what I'm trying
to get us to
look that's really the only argument
we're gonna have Back to the Future one
is is is is a masterpiece much like a
New Hope is a masterpiece sure Back to
the Future two is not as good as Back to
the Future one but it's fun it's great
Empire Strikes Back
super it's better yeah than the original
Masterpiece agreed
Return of the Jedi lands the ship
clumsily but enough Back To The Future
Three is one of the worst sequels I have
ever seen in my entire how on Earth now
why now I never you always say this to
me but you never [ __ ] you just
quantify with [ __ ] you're like it's
about doc why is it about doc shouldn't
be the entire franchise is based on the
mcflys that is the entire franchise it
is based on Marty McFly this kid that
doesn't get his family whose family are
these dejected losers every person the
uncle's a jail bird the mom's an
alcoholic the dad's a Yachts yeah the
sister is a mess he fixed them the
brother is [ __ ] up it's every person
in this family is yeah and then he is
sent back he wants nothing to do with
these people and he is sent back in time
accidentally to save not only the life
of his best friend doc the only person
he can relate to because he from such a
dysfunctional family hangs out with an
older man who's a scientist right
which is so odd right yeah but the whole
point is is he goes back and he fixes
his family yeah at the end of Back to
the Future one doc comes shows up in the
time machine what's what's going on
Marty you saved your parents yeah now
it's your kids yeah we have to go into
the future we have to go back to the
future she coins the phrase and
justifies the title in the last two
minutes of the movie oh he said he said
it in in one yeah
no no no no no he says it he says it in
one before that we're going to send you
back to the future he says that in one
like I think he only says it at the end
where do we gotta go back back to the
future he's well whatever it might be
right but I I they spin the title then
right twice this isn't it the 1.21 he's
like when he tells him about the
lightning he's like this is it this is
it we're gonna I thought it was there
but I think it's only at the end but
even if he says it twice sure the end
the end usage of it gives it a a whole
new meaning from what the entire story
that the end of two is just as fun but
we're not talking about that hold on
what are we talking about what we're
talking about is is there it is see I
told you I could bring it out of anybody
the uh what we're talking about is at
the end he says now it's about your kids
and that's and then you get into two and
this is where the problems start folks I
run hot not just emotionally not just
mentally but physically I'm always hot
especially when I sleep I hate getting
hot when I sleep a lot of the time that
has to do with the sheets you're
sleeping on you're betting and that's
where I like Miracle brand okay
it's hard enough in the summertime to
deal with the heat and I know we're
coming out of Summer but guys I got news
for you in a lot of places it's still
going to be warm for quite some time and
I find that Miracle brand is a great way
to stay cool at night so I don't wake up
sticky and sweaty uh you know this is
eco-friendly bedding such as sheets
pillowcases and comforters that prevent
prevent 99 of by the way bacteria
because that's what happens when you're
sweating in your bedding bacteria grows
and stuff and this requires three times
less laundry because of how they are
preventing these things from happening
they have self-cooling properties
uh it's a silver infused fabric that it
was originally developed by NASA I'm
stalled Miracle brand sheets are uh
here's a word you don't hear often
thermoregulating and designed to keep
you at the perfect temperature all night
long self-cleaning because the sheets
are infused with a natural silver that
prevents 99.9 of bacterial growth all
right uh they're luxurious Comfort
they're quality okay 500 thread count
sateen weave that's made with us grown
supima cotton it's just better on your
skin it's better for you everything
about this is better so go to try
miracle.com tastebuds again try
miracle.com taste buds here's the deal
you're gonna get if you use our promo
code taste buds at checkout you're going
to save 40 and get three free towels
they got towels too
Miracle is so confident in their product
it's backed by a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you're not 100 satisfied
you get your full refund no worries
upgrade your sleep with Miracle brand go
to try miracle.com tastebuds use the
code taste buds and get three
free towels
and say 40 off again that's try
miracle.com taste buds thank you
miraclebrand for sponsoring this episode
hello fresh hello Fresh So Fresh hello
fresh hello fresh hello fresh subscribe
to hellofresh and check save money off
your fall to-do list you want to save
some money this fall I know you do I do
you don't have to worry about it with
hello fresh hello fresh is 25 cheaper
than takeout and less expensive than
grocery shopping with hellofresh
ingredients travel from the farm to your
doorstep in less than seven days so you
know that they're Fresh Plus
pre-portioned ingredients make cooking a
snap and cut down on food waste that's
one thing I hate when I cook a lot for
myself
and one thing I like about the meal kits
versus doing everything my cobbling all
together myself is I end up with a with
a considerable amount of food waste as a
guy that lives alone
I feel bad about that you just can't get
through all of it and trust me when I
tell you people I have had many times in
my life where I've gone out into the
street with leftover food and tried to
find somebody to give it to and and and
and not I had failed not been able to
find anybody I know that sounds
surprising living in New York City but
it's true I like that hellofresh is
giving you what you need what you're
going to use it's it's appropriate
amounts and you're not wasting uh food I
I really really like that about them I
also like that hello fresh is here to
work with your ever-changing schedule
our schedules change plans are flexible
you can choose your meals for the week
you can update your preferences you can
change your delivery day all with the
app or with the app and changing seasons
means changing tastes with 30 plus
weekly recipes to choose from hellofresh
is something for everyone you can
customize your meals you can swap out
the proteins you can swap out the sides
you can upgrade to Choice proteins you
can add protein to a veggie meal you can
do all kinds of stuff I think it's
really really great so anyway go to
hellofresh.com
tastebuds65 and use code taste buds six
five for 65 off plus free shipping go to
hellofresh.com
tastebuds65 and use code
tastebuds65 for 65 percent off plus free
shipping hellofresh America's number one
meal kit
they spend about a hot 15 minutes yeah
working on Marty's kids sure and then
they go back
and they get greedy then they go back to
1985 and it's Biff 1985. yeah then they
go back to the [ __ ] past again and
they do way too much in the sequel that
has disagree and they do so much in the
sequel these [ __ ] gavones they got
nothing left for the third movie what
does that mean I mean what does gavones
it means like a like a pig like a gaboon
but you didn't love like burn out what
they got they burn it they have nothing
left for three
even says I always wanted to do a
western I thought it'd be fun to do a
western party I think he was right but
like the the two I was trying to do
Pinocchio too
we all get old all right we all lose our
touch like he and I didn't even see
Pinocchio so I don't even know if I
agree with you I may love it but like
this thing is is like he but you didn't
like do you get into the aspect of it as
like where I'm like wow at one point in
1955 there's five Deloreans
and I love [ __ ] like that that's cool
yeah but you can't have that without
three you can't have it without all the
time travel like all of them
but it takes you but like you're saying
like all right it's about his family and
kids where I'm just like wow two's
really about like how [ __ ] chaotic
and [ __ ] up things you get when you
start [ __ ] with the time stream but
that's the icing
that's not the iPhone no no here's what
I'm saying here's what I'm saying Star
Wars the kids are the least Star Wars
exciting part of part two but here's my
because they [ __ ] it up here's my
point also it didn't help that they made
part two and three five years after the
first one it was too much of a gap but
here's my point
Star Wars yeah
and and where they went wrong with the
sequel trilogy
and where they went wrong with the
prequels too
is they get away from the point of the
original trilogy which is the family
it's about Luke coming to terms with his
father well hold on hold on it's why the
Godfather it's why the Godfather works
it's about the family it's not about the
mob
Back to the Future is about the family
it's not about time he saves Doc in the
first one but it's a but it's a story
about the family fur that's got to be
the foundation but it's so my point is
why does it have to be the foundation
it's about time good storytelling yeah
but he he goes back but it's about like
Doc is so you're saying Doc's not part
of his family because he's not blood
related I know I I get that you could
make the argument that even the dog
and the first one he saves doc but he
already saved his family in the first
one so why do you want to see that over
and over because plus it's a western
like because future [ __ ] I don't want to
see future [ __ ] because it's never going
to be true I could tell you what the
third one should have been I promise you
and this is better this is a better idea
okay okay
the way trilogies work I think this is
Joseph uh Campbell right sure many faces
I think this is his like theory on
trilogies
first one is the adventure yeah second
one is the deeper emotional Journey
third one brings you back to the
elements of the first one okay which is
exactly what the original Star Wars
certainly one way to skin a cat but it's
it's a great way to to deal with a
fantasy story it's exactly what back to
the it's exactly what Star Wars the
original trilogy does the first time and
I know by the way I already hear it in
the comments The Roaster said it's about
the franchise is only talking about was
the original trilogy I'm getting it it's
okay but my point is this though you I
think you're ignoring this though hold
on I think you're ignoring this I I want
you to finish that but like it's a movie
about time travel they have to make that
exciting we've seen 55 we've seen the
Future movie I think that's [ __ ] cool
it's it's not a self-conscious movie
a self-conscious movie means it can't be
the movie without the genre itself okay
in other words literally cannot make
that movie without time travel but you
could in theory okay you could say this
is not a movie about time travel this is
a movie about a guy saving his family
the time travel is the world that we're
setting it in so in other words
Good Fellas
Goodfellas is a movie that cannot take
place outside of the mob world it is
entirely reliant on being a mafia movie
okay every single thing that moves that
movie Forward is related to the mafia
period The Godfather could be about
real estate it could be about oil it
could be about a million things outside
of the mob because at its core it's a
really about the family okay Back to the
Future in my opinion yeah at its core is
much less about time travel and way more
about a kid that is trying to save his
family they just tell it in a very
fantastic way that's my opinion but the
third one is I think if you because you
are you're talking about how you view it
through different ways but you can make
the argument that the third one is about
him saving his family too that's dead
he's like I'm gonna go back was already
dead though we already did that and
they're just redoing it but that's all
right but but so is the family but
that's but so much but here's how it
could have been cooler you ready I'm
ready here's how it could have been cool
and it would have it was it's Joseph no
Campbell then this would reflect cam you
gotta stop [ __ ] handjobbing this
Joseph Campbell yeah he's only the guy
that influenced George Lucas to write
the original yeah but then George Lucas
did what he did yeah well but here's
listen to me
Back to the Future too should have been
this uh it should have been Marty going
to the Future yeah
it should have been a better version and
telling of that story
and it should have been his Adventure in
the future in Saving his kids you would
have wiped Hill Valley I'm not listen to
me and then your Cliffhanger at the end
and this gives me chills when I say it
because I've said it out loud before
part two ends with Marty going back to
1985 going I did it I saved the day he
shows up and the last shot is him
walking into that town square and you
see the chaos right and you realize Biff
has done something awful and then the
third one hold on the third one
is now him in 1985 alternate dealing
with that and then going back to the 50s
so it brings us full circle to the
original movie to save his mother from
what Biff has turned his family into
through his power yeah but but but you
got all that they they got they gave you
that they rushed through it so we can
get to it what did you want they rush
through it like how much more you know
I'm right you know that would have made
for a much more Dynamic Trilogy I don't
know about that I love three I the way I
look at is this I love that they were
like let's [ __ ] go crazy it's a Time
Machine movie let's get back and show
something that like if they had went to
ancient Rome I would have liked it like
I like that they were finally like we
have a time machine let's break it out
of this and you know what it should have
been the third one what do you know what
it should have been and I've said this
too it should have been Bill and Ted it
should have been him time jumping
through all different periods on some
crazy whatever they blew this third
movie by making because Robert zemeckis
and what's his face had a hard on to
make a [ __ ] Western and they
shoehorned it into a goddamn franchise
when you have a time machine you could
just go to the old west who wants to see
that I want to see it this is an amazing
amazing movie about technology and we're
going into a place that has zero
technology right so how do they get out
of that situation
I love that idea and I love that
DeLorean was buried for all that time I
love that they had to make I I mean I
guess me I like the chip on the like I
love the look of the DeLorean with the
white wall tires I'll knock my I'll
knock my own I'll knock my own you don't
even watch Back To The Future Three
that's the [ __ ] that they have you watch
it half of it when it first came out
through it and then so you didn't even
watch it
it's up to a pile of [ __ ] and bury my
nose in it to know it's a pilot but
everybody calls a pile of [ __ ] a pile of
[ __ ] Back to the Future Part three a lot
of people are like including me I love
this movie so it's like I will knock my
own franchise I will knock my own
franchise right now I will knock my own
franchise in defense in order to support
my own point back
is exactly why Star Wars fans they hated
the [ __ ] Phantom Menace why because
instead of giving us a movie about dog
fights in space and space pirates and
all these things we loved and family
let's do a movie about political trade
routes and you're like I don't want to
do this but that's not what they did
they made a movie about time machine
where they got stuck in a situation that
they had to get out and they took every
fun it's but they didn't they had the
same [ __ ] half the castle all the two
movies were in it it's all rehashes of
jokes for the third time for the third
time that we had to you're here back in
good old
1885. I mean I'll give you that one
yeah I gotta give you that one no matter
oh he drove into a pile of Manoa why
don't you why do you accept it why do
you accept that Biff is it prick he's
his grandson's a prick but not his great
grandfather's a prick he's a prick fine
yeah but the point is is they do the
same joke he drives into the [ __ ]
manure they do the thing yeah but how
many times does Star Wars are like I got
a bad feeling about this it's the same
you stop
[Music]
it's the same thing it's not the same
thing it's just I got a bad feeling
about this everybody in the galaxy far
far away has a bad joke phrase that's a
catch phrase that they plan each no come
on you know that that's weak ass
[ __ ] sauce it's a it's a it's a
callback it's the same thing what I'm
saying about Back To The Future Three is
the same criticism you could like if you
had your [ __ ] together against the force
awakens right now that it's a rehashing
of [ __ ] you've already nobody nobody at
home wants to hear [ __ ] us talking
about Force awakens
attack my franchise
I'm telling you because I got I got all
the Time in the World to attack yours we
don't I got a [ __ ] god with 12 31 I
was supposed to be out here at 12 30. I
gotta go I don't gotta go anywhere you
sit here after you leave and [ __ ] about
it
it's [ __ ] jar jar on screen listen I
can't
I my point is this is it's like you have
such a strong angry opinion of a movie
that you haven't even watched
seen you never watched the whole thing
I've seen it in its entirety I'm the one
that's got to get my [ __ ] together but
you've never even seen the [ __ ] I've
seen it in its entirety out of sequence
and I've tried several times to sit
through it from start to finish I can't
get through it it's a bad movie it's not
a bad movie it's a fun movie
oh no don't die don't die come on what
are you doing eating pretzels while
you're screaming
Back To The Future Three All Right Back
to the Future feet you know what it is
Back to Future Three feels like
when they do a [ __ ] a movie about a
sitcom that went off the air it feels
like The Facts of Life go to Europe
or they'd be like Different Strokes are
back and Different Strokes go to the old
west that's what Back to the Future
you're telling me you wouldn't [ __ ]
watched Back to the Future I mean an old
west Facts of Life Of course you'd watch
that this was [ __ ] sweet dude this is
a time machine this is what we should be
doing it's your argument you're the one
that brought it up you would watch it
you're telling me you would not watch
Facts of Life going to the old west I
would [ __ ] pay money to see that
today come on man Mary steenberg and
what do you got to get it reminds me of
it reminds me of like getting the car
getting pushed by the train such a
[ __ ] great idea and I'm not saying
that there aren't elements in Back to
the Future Three that create suspense
you don't like Doc
I love doc so then why don't you want
Doc to be happy I just he's got kids
he's got Jewels he's got burn not that
that they bring in a [ __ ] they said this
they go we felt that in the third movie
it was time for Doc to have a love
interest why not shut up nobody cares
about weird doc having sex I a [ __ ]
other thing I'd watch if I had the
ability Mary steenberg and her hottest
this bag in this [ __ ] okay
[Music]
you think you can't dance is the hottest
man that ever lived he is gorgeous Sam
Malone I'm not going against that but
that's why it's a [ __ ] movie man and
they had those two kids Einstein like
they got him out of suspended animation
Einstein and whatever he named the
[ __ ] predicus oh Jules and Burn yeah
Jules and Vern you didn't name your kid
Marty when he brings that [ __ ] kid
forward he goes why would he name that
kid Marty what why would he name the kid
Marty after the guy that just saved his
ass
so what his best friend dude Q you're
telling me when doc brings the kids
forward he goes jewels and then he
brings the second gear forward he goes
and you're literally going Marty no and
then he goes Vern and you go oh because
this [ __ ] Third Rate [ __ ] uh love
interest that you just brought in likes
Jules [ __ ] Vern we're naming the
[ __ ] kids after yeah after the guy
that saved the [ __ ] universe and and
your [ __ ] ass can't risk like I
didn't come back to the old west you
think doc looks at Marty like he saved
the universe or does he think the two of
them saved the Universe I think doc owes
Marty a lot at the end at the end I
think I think Marty I think Marty allows
for Doc to have the life doc always
dreamed of if you want to get into the
importance of Doc yeah
it DOC does not have the time train or
any of that [ __ ] without Marty coming
back to save his [ __ ] ass okay okay
on the ground if it wasn't for Marty
bringing him the letter in the first
movie dude his family wouldn't exist and
those kids wouldn't exist if not for the
writings of Jules Verne so why is that
not something that you could be like I
can name my kids after this me and my
wife love it they were obviously in the
past for another eight [ __ ] years
while they built the train it's just
it's just come on dude it's it's that is
the moment where they show you they have
forgotten what the [ __ ] this Trilogy is
about the most that is ending they are
so far I'm telling you though they are
so far from the point of everything that
they don't name that kid Marty
you can't
Rebels
so [ __ ] out there that I don't even
know how to like he's uh you see how
angry he is that doctor the name is kid
Marty like what how am I supposed to
even
this hey Marty here's my new kids Vidal
and Sassoon who gives a [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] because that wouldn't connect to
the movie that wouldn't connection
because that's why they fell in love
because of the writings that's my point
you're gonna bring this [ __ ] broad in
and she's getting the names on the kids
in the third installment it's not going
to be Marty give me a break dude it
would be more [ __ ] sense if he named
the kid Biff for Christ's sakes Biff and
Marty it would have made more friends
after all these guys have been through
dude what are you talking about man oh
come on he fell in love with her over
Jules Verne they had kids out of that
love and then named him Jules and Vern I
don't think that's a stretch out of all
the things to complain about I don't
know that that kind of strain is a
disgrace why is the time but we don't
even have time wait what sort of tech
what else would he make if he what are
you talking about if he was stuck in the
past I I know you hate the times because
he had to create a vehicle to get him to
the Future because what else would he
use
because I can tell you why okay I can
tell you why
you said it's what you said at the
beginning of your argument in the first
movie when he makes a time machine out
of that DeLorean yeah
it's all taped together it's all like
you can see the [ __ ] Scotch tape yeah
and you're like [ __ ] this almost
seems plausible right it almost seems
believable it runs on plutonium yeah
it's the whole story about how he had to
steal the every element about it you're
like
this actually seems pretty [ __ ]
plausible when that stupid train flies
in with the wheels and it's all glossy
and gleamy and perfect and all that [ __ ]
it ruins it it sucks it's like in when
it's like in Phantom Menace when the
heroes are driving around in the [ __ ]
silver uh Platinum ship that looks like
a [ __ ] like perfect like Trans Am
spaceship or whatever the Naboo uh
Cruiser yeah it ruins it dude that's not
what this is that's not what the
technology that looks like something out
of like a Mickey's [ __ ] Christmas
Carol or some [ __ ] like that that sucks
dude and you know that that sucks I
don't think that sucks why does that
suck it looks absurd it looks extreme it
looks like a Disney cartoon no the way
it flies in with the [ __ ]
uh with the moving wheels and all that
it's a flying train we can agree that
Mary steenberg's pretty [ __ ] pretty
[ __ ] cute in this moment I told you
she's at her [ __ ] Peak and I'm
supposed to believe she's banging this
[ __ ] ghost
oh there they are Jules and burn but
that sucks dude come on I don't think
that sucks uh Brian that sucks look it's
got Wings it's flies
dude it sucks he what else would he
build the time machine out of back then
oh my god of course could he build that
he's [ __ ] doc doc [ __ ] brown man
like yeah with no reason he so he can't
get his own ass out of the [ __ ] old
west but he builds a Time train well he
no that wasn't the problem he probably
could have but the deadline was
a mad dog shot him in like six days
seven days whatever it was I don't know
man all right look I gotta go I I can't
I gotta go I mean look I got it I
thought I'd have to at least kind of
defend Star Wars uh I don't know but I
didn't really have to at all well we
spent a lot of time talking about Evil
Dead and it's always sunny
yeah all right pip let's go to the
phones real quick because because Q's
got to get out of here
uh a low-key went back to the future win
but you cannot stop Star Wars
Back to the Future is Iconic Star Wars
is a diluted brand that's what I thought
you were going to go after a little bit
more because I agree with that actually
yeah but I still think Star Wars is
better I never really made a point about
saying why I thought star well because I
don't really have anything to argue
because I love Star Wars so much it's
hard for me to be like I could give you
something I think Star Wars as an
overall franchise did a better job of
keeping me intrigued and sticking to at
least somewhat to the lineage of what
brought me there in the first place I
don't think Star Wars ever went
quite as
far maybe if there was a Back to the
Future four I'd feel differently I don't
know but I really think three completely
ruins the goddamn franchise will you go
see the Broadway show yeah we'll go see
that I'll see you all right let's go see
let's go see it all right all right be
fair I've never seen Star Wars clear
bias Back to the Future easily such a
cool 80s time capsule with a well-told
story
and ended before the corporation Mouse
could get to defile it like it did with
Star Wars this is I knew this would be
the argument
I got to be honest you might [ __ ] win
because people are hating on Star Wars
right now
easy Star Wars had only siblings that
wanted to bone Back to the Future I had
a mother wanted to sleep with her future
son here's the other thing I I I I I in
total Clarity I told you this before we
recorded uh to the audience at home like
I know people that work on the Star Wars
shows so even if I wanted to trash him I
you know I have to walk out of here
there's a [ __ ] failed admission right
there yeah like even if I even if I
wanted to trash him I couldn't so I'm
kind of in a spot where it's like well
I'll trash Star Wars I just think it's a
spin-off of the Bible we're back to the
future's original content I see I'll
rest on that good point pimp I'll rest
on that uh Back to the Future all day
because a guy almost [ __ ] his mom is
way cooler than a guy almost [ __ ] his
sister let's give that the win that's
pretty funny
Dan Scully at Dan Scully follow at
s-c-u-l-o-y thank you Dan
uh do you have a sister
huh you don't have a sister no why I
don't have a sister so I never like that
never grossed me out like a grossed
other people out because I don't know
and I'm adopted so Marty almost I didn't
know that I'm kidding I'm really joking
okay I'm joking I'm joking the Marty mom
thing always did gross me out but it is
weird how they play it because what's
your name
um Brian oh Elia Thompson Leah Thompson
Leah Leah Thompson they couldn't have
made her hotter no in that scene where
she kisses her own son they made like
the shoulders [ __ ] cleavage out like
she looks like a dream man they've got
her powdered so she looks like like so
fair so yeah like it's weird they're
they're clearly being like it's kind of
weird right like they're not just being
like Oh it's awkward they're being like
what would you do yeah and let me tell
you something I I did that episode of
Picard a few last year she directed it
oh wow it's like even with the covid
mask on and I think she's like 61. she's
gorgeous I was like I was like I
reverted back to that that's gorgeous
I'm like oh my god daughter I love her
so much daughter is really
smoking and I say that with all due
respect all due respect I really do I'm
not being a [ __ ] yeah daughter is
beautiful really yeah and you're like
man I remember when your mom was your
age and she was beautiful all right I'm
stuck in that family what do we got I
got I do have to run I'm sorry
that's a pretty big that's a pretty big
win to 39.8 it's not as big as a lot of
people would have been a lot of people
would have bet that it would have been
pummeling on Star Wars part that's a
nice margin but I gotta tell you I for a
minute thought that Back to the Future
might win because Star Wars people had
more options to [ __ ] to bed yeah and and
Back to the Future it does have that
thing as it's been so long yeah that
like you could paper over the well you
can but like a lot of people could paper
over the aspects like you said like back
in Old 1985 you know 1955 like when you
said that I had to lift because that was
corny and [ __ ] but like that doesn't
Factor because it's been so long it
doesn't Factor so I tell you what I'm
gonna give yet another chance to Back To
The Future Three I have it on Blu-rays
made me this promise before I'll give it
a shot again
let's watch it together all right let's
watch it let's watch it okay all right
we always end with I still love you oh I
still love you
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic